jury selection starts today in a lawsuit
against former president Trump his
lawyer says he has no plans to attend
the trial former advice columnist 18
Carroll claims Trump attacked her
decades ago then defamed her when she
went public many years later Elaine
Keanu has a preview of the civil court
trial and we should note some of the
details of this case are disturbing
[Applause]
Donald Trump runs for reelection his
attorneys are preparing for another
legal battle
former L magazine writer E Gene Carroll
alleges Trump raped her in the mid-90s
in a New York Department Store dressing
room she never reported the alleged
assault to police and first shared her
story with the public in her 2019
autobiography by then it was too late
for a criminal investigation but a New
York state law allowed Carol to file a
civil lawsuit I'm filing this lawsuit
not just for myself but for every woman
in America who's been grabbed groped
harassed sexually assaulted Trump has
repeatedly denied the allegations he
called Carol's claim a hoax and a lie
used to promote her book and said quote
she's not my type more than a dozen
women have accused Trump of sexual
assault or harassment he denies all the
allegations and none of those claims
have gone to trial until today none of
these cases have ever been able to
really find him liable let alone guilty
CBS News legal analyst Ricky cleeman
says Carol could win because of the
lower burden of proof in civil cases
Eugene Carroll by filing a civil case
only has to satisfy these jurors that it
is more likely than not that by a
preponderance of the evidence that
Donald Trump committed this sexual
assault
if Trump is found liable he will have to
pay damages to Carroll based on the
trauma that jurors believe she suffered
now in another legal fight this one in
Georgia we've learned the Fulton County
D.A will reveal this summer whether
Trump or his allies will face criminal
charges related to alleged election
interference in 2020. Gail
yep more to come on that too thank you
Elaine